you brother have to stop wearing anxiety
as an identity badge as a way you walk
around the world this is this is my this
is the way I do it and you have to take
those intellectual conversations that
you have and those lessons that you
think about and think about and those
hard conversations and you have to start
doing things
differently and that means you're GNA
have to start getting
tougher and I don't mean that like I
don't feel my anxiety I mean tougher
like I'm going to do things when I don't
feel like it
I'm going to exercise when I don't feel
like it I'm going to go to work and be
on time when I don't feel like it I'm
going to ask my wife every single day of
my life how can I love you today